we got so many literal glasses these
days though they just they don't get it
like they just read things and they're
like oh my God but even if it's a joke
it's like no that is that's the [__]
point well some of them are just so
ready to react angrily plus I'm sure
there's cool vegans
but where are they
[Music]
there is a new dating app on the scene
who do you think it caters to
let me think wow actually I'm not sure
how new it is dude it's not for well I
guess it could be I thought of you boys
recently I saw this trailer for a new
show about farmers who are dating people
and I was like we should all watch this
together oh it's a TV show it's a
farmer's dating show dude it's like
Farmers Only [__] but it's like on
television cool it's like nice it's the
kind of [__] that we love like watching
Mormons try to [__] each other
now we get my favorite exactly now we
get to watch Farmers try to do it it's
gonna be fun who do you think this
dating asks for pets racists is it for
racists racists not quite not race what
he yeah I guess they could be racist but
twins is good wins I saw a conspiracy
these ones have it rough for the dating
world who do you think family members
who do you think has trouble finding a
partner uh due to a certain way that
they live
oh homeless people
oh did you have a homeless homeless baby
I thought you just unzipped the front
door and you go in you think we're going
better apps through this yeah
it's got to do with diet fat people no
no cause you're so fat you can't leave
the house yeah oh yeah if you gotta get
cut out of the house carnivores close
vegan yeah really vegans yeah it's
called Grazer I guess that makes a lot
of us at some carnivores
yeah cause they got to eat at the same
place that makes way more sense than fat
chicks who gotta get cut out of their
house
hey man
I'm gonna make it that guest fat chicks
gotta get cut out of their house it's
like you're gonna so you're gonna need a
helicopter too
probably yeah you're gonna need a lot
can you imagine when they first meet
when they cut out the whole house so
that they open it up and then they get a
[__] they look at the palette and
then they put the bed on the pallet and
then the [__] the other guy has to do
that too so then you just have these two
[__] uh well then you gotta cut the
roof off the restaurant yeah
oh my God the two fat [__] coming down
two fat [__] that'll be tight dude
that's the name of that two fat [__]
that's like three hundred thousand
dollars worth of a first date hey but
that's also 300 000 pounds of a love 300
000. it's also an economic need also the
the waiter is in for a big tip that
night because you know they're gonna eat
the whole unless it's all you can eat
yeah so do we have room for dessert that
was a joke here you go here you go here
you go
dude that fast
and four chairs it's not only that this
app now exists it's that they launched a
really clever ad Campaign which I
thought was amazing with this really
great catchphrase and to follow the
stereotypes of vegans not having a sense
of humor they got mad it has to do with
the pun of meeting meat that's really
great but not quite that's a good one
what oh that's actually great yeah
that's dope but they got mad because
they didn't get it that's what they call
Meta they didn't get it they got pissed
I like that one they needed to switch
around vegans [__] am I the best one I
know but they didn't like it they didn't
understand why they like the most
angriest group out there lack of iron I
feel like vegan and Pita go along real
well together that was deeper that was
deeper than people know lack of iron was
deep in there
oh dang that was so deep I just
registered it and we're still on the
[__] two fat [__]
they're like Two Broke Girls but like a
spin-off yeah two fat bumps
like a vegan hierarchy in the ass
somebody knock it out of the park with
this that's [__] [__] that's like
they created like FUBU for us bias and
they're like what are you trying to say
I'm trying to say it's for us buy us you
stupid [__] God damn trying to make it
like would you call me did you call me a
FUBU yeah it's like what the [__] it it
feels like it came from within the
community it did yeah like it came from
like not from like other people that
don't know the culture creating It came
it sounds like people from inside oh
it'll be so tight we got so many literal
dumbasses these days though they just
they don't get it like they just read
things and they're like oh my God but
even if it's a joke it's like no that
that's the [__] point well some of
them are just so ready to react angrilia
it's like it's like a hip fire reflex
plus I'm sure there's cool vegans
but where are they
well I keep hearing about them I've
never met a vegan that did it properly
like I've met vegans but the the whole
time like I'll watch and I'm like you do
know soy sauce is made out of fish broth
okay
exactly bro well like you know the best
vegans are the ones that are slightly
flexible you know what I'm saying like
they they know how to be like yeah I'm a
vegan but when they're in a situation
socially with people that I can make it
work true you know what I mean it's like
I know that's not perfect but it's okay
maybe we can do something like this no
my favorite vegans are the ones who are
like you know hey I'm pretty chill like
I just don't use animal products and
then they get on a jet
that's my favorite those are my favorite
kinds of vegans
on a [__] leather interior leather
interior by the way with [__]
dinosaurs blowing out the back of the
exhaust give me a [__] break I
remember to I have I had a really uh
good friend of mine who's vegan for like
three years and we were walking together
to this bar and I was walking in front
of him eating kyochon chicken like wings
and he was like that smells really good
and I'm like yeah do you want one I was
just joking he's all actually yeah I'm
gonna try one and I was like dude
this chicken smelled really good I wish
I could tell kyochon bro you know how
good your chicken is that's like so good
we make a vegan meat Terrier it is good
it's like one of my favorite stories I
heard I think Joe Rogan was saying that
he was on a plane with Norm Macdonald
and then
um nor McDonald was talking about like
smoking he's like oh yeah no I don't
smoke I gave up smoke and I don't smoke
anymore and then he was like bashing it
yeah he's like he's [__] on it the
whole time and then he gets off the
plate and he goes and he buys some
cigarettes immediately and then he
starts smoking and the airport and
Jordan's like I thought you know smoking
was like oh yeah no I I picked it up
again
[Laughter]
immediately from talking about it that
much yeah did he forget I don't know
that's just he lives a bit man that's
the crazy thing so good that's hilarious
so there is a spokesperson for uh this
app and it's I believe it's this uh this
drag performer named Bimini and even
this person was like yeah vegans can go
[__] themselves which is funny because
that matches the that's really good
really good that's really good because
even they were pissed that the vegans
didn't get it so yeah oh also now that
if you wanted why do you think they're
they have such a bad rep and like like
the influencers like the vegan influence
and like the way that they talk and then
like when someone starts bringing up
vegan [__] like it's so [__] annoying
it's condescending it's the influencers
I think though yeah because it's not the
real vegan Community the ones that I've
known in person and met face to face
they're all cool like like what you said
like they don't we're just eating at a
restaurant they're like oh just find
something else and then they're just a
human being they don't make it their
personality dude in like in like 2015
like everyone like a couple chick
influencers went vegan everybody starts
going vegan after that and then everyone
got all proselytizing about it and like
well I'm just vegan so like sorry yo I'm
so sorry I'm vegan and so then it became
that it was after conspiracy it was
exactly exactly that [__] just made me
hungrier cheese that's why they think
Asians are Savage dude I did after
things like cowspiracy I tried uh going
vegan for and I think I lasted like two
months and I was like this is impossible
and not fun and then I was like let me
try vegetarian and then I lasted for
like six months then I was like that
also was very difficult and now I love
eating meat again like amazingly meat
just smells so good my mom's been
vegetarian for over 20 years she stays
with me and then like when I cook food
I'll make her her own separate thing and
then I should be like oh what are you
cooking in the kitchen I saw her [__]
steak you know I'm like this is what I'm
making she's like oh
didn't smell that good by the way I love
to use of impossible that was really
good nice so when Nikki started going
into to vegetarian space
um the way that they season their Foods
especially in Thai food restaurants it's
[__] bomb Asians are really good at
vegetarians they can't they cannot rely
on some [__] yeah they have to like
be extracurricular with the spices and
[__] and so they bring it because you're
gonna need to [__] make tofu taste
good right and they've been doing it for
centuries exactly yeah the [__] monk
look I would do vegan vegetarian
anything if it's Thai food but other
than that I'm out you know I went to The
Shaolin Temple and uh they [__] yeah
we shot a video though in China yeah in
China cool man and so all the monks
there well my partner at the time her
aunt was the director of the university
for all the kids that like basically
just like a boarding school for all the
boys that have to go learn Kung Fu so
anyways like she's running the
university so all the monks there are
all vegetarians and but they're so
crafty that they use I don't [__]
know how to do it but they literally use
vegetables to make meat substitutes but
they also look smell and taste and
texturally feel like meat I'm talking
like it looks like a shrimp it looks
like a shrimp it tastes like a shrimp
but it's vegetarian that looks like
bacon or a sausage or whatever and it's
like the [__] it's really you taste
it makes vegetarian IHOP
yes it does [__] bacon and sausage
and [__] what was the bacon really made
out of here
I didn't even understand the language
wait is it true part is it true or is it
not true that okay even if a monk is
like I'm a vegetarian if I bring him
like a bunch of beef jerky they gotta
eat it a true Buddhist monk that's
sticking to their morals they're
supposed to eat oh because you're the
one they're supposed to be begging for
food like they're taking they don't have
possessions it's just a bowl they're all
out of bowls and they're both and the
food you put in there
you're you're eating for sustenance so
you separate your like senses from it so
they should be eating it dude ever since
you told me that I think about that all
the time and like he's gonna get roasted
no one no once you know once crypticals
back where it's gonna go
and like once I start doing some troll
[__] again
I'm gonna go to a [__] Buddhist
temple and I'm just gonna keep being
like all I got is ribs I'm sorry
oh crib oh it's all a guy I got
short ribs
realistically though they might just eat
it and I'll give a [__] but I got ribs
and bibs so here's they're gonna love it
dude they're gonna be like I guess I
have to eat the ribs again son of a
[__]
[Laughter]
which one
[Music]
thank you